-My next guests have nearly
160 million TikTok followers
between them.
They host
a weekly podcast called
"Charli and Dixie: 2 Chix."
And this summer, their family
will be the subject of
a new docu-series called
"The D'Amelio Show."
Here are
Charli and Dixie D'Amelio.
Ah, look. Come on.
Look at the sisters.
I'm so happy you're here.
A lot of times, we'll ask guests
what they've been up to
in quarantine.
Dixie, in your case,
you launched a music career.
-Yes.
-Giant, by the way.
You released your song
"Be Happy" in June.
It has over
100 million YouTube views,
70 million streams on Spotify.
Wow! Did you realize it was
going to be that much of a hit?
-I mean, I honestly had no idea
that that would happen at all.
I've always wanted to do it
but never really thought
it could happen,
and then it did pretty well.
-Pretty well?
Oh, my -- Pretty well?
Are you kidding me?
Any plans for more music?
Is there an album in the works?
Anything that you can tell us?
-Definitely an album
at some point,
but my next song
is coming out April 9th,
which I'm very excited about.
-Love it.
Alright, new jam from Dixie.
Alright, good.
What did you think --
Because you didn't join
TikTok right away.
Charli joined first.
What did you think when
you saw her making TikToks?
Were you like, "Cool,
I want to do that"?
-You can be honest.
-[ Laughs ]
She started at a time
where TikTok was
still really embarrassing,
and I was really embarrassed
that she was posting.
And my friends at school were
very into what she was doing.
And I was like, "Oh, my gosh.
She is so weird,"
blah, blah, blah.
-She told me.
She was like,
"I just hit a 100K."
And I was like,
"Oh, my goodness.
This is so insane."
She was like, "Talk to me when
you hit a million,"
and that's when she joined.
-Yeah.
And then a little competition.
But, Charli, I noticed
that you started changing up
your content
a little bit recently.
You're posting reviews of
things like --
I don't know
what was one I just saw.
Kinetic sand I think I saw.
-Yeah.
-How do you know what your
followers are going to be into?
-If I'm going to be
honest with you,
it was what I was doing on
a day-to-day basis.
I was doing reviews
to myself in the mirror
and I was like,
"Why don't I film this?
This is so much fun.
Maybe people will enjoy it."
I know what people like
changes very often,
and I was like, "Why don't I
share this with everyone
and see what they think?"
And I did, and people
actually really liked it.
-Do you think that is the key
to being successful
on social media,
just being honest?
-I think so.
I feel like you have to be
as authentic as you can be,
because people can tell
when you're not being authentic,
and they don't resonate
with that as much.
-Before you started
doing this, Charli,
you were a competitive dancer.
Would you ever go back to that?
-I actually just started getting
back into training.
We got a dance studio in my
house, which is so amazing.
Really never thought
that that would happen.
And I've been working
very closely with Blake McGrath,
who has kind of brought me from,
like, being out of dance
and feeling self-conscious
about myself,
because I felt
like every time I danced,
I had to, like,
prove something to everyone,
and that is not
what dance is about.
And he really helped me
find myself again.
And we are going to be
working on a solo
for this year, so hopefully
I can get back into
the competition scene,
because I really miss it.
-Well, you're on Time magazine's
TIME100 Next" list,
and the person that writes about
you is Jennifer Lopez.
What?!
Dude, you have to be happy.
You have to be excited.
That is legendary.
-That was insane.
I didn't know
she was writing about me
until I woke up
and I saw everyone was like,
"Oh, my goodness.
J.Lo wrote this about you."
And I was like, "Wait. Hold on.
That's not real.
That didn't happen.
I don't know what's going on."
That was insane to me
when I saw that.
What she said
really made me feel
so great
and so confident in myself,
because she made me feel like
I matter to her,
and having your idol
acknowledge you like that
is something so
amazing and something
I never thought
would have happened.
-You have your own docu-series
coming to Hulu this summer.
It's called "The D'Amelio show."
I'm excited about that,
but are you -- Is it everything?
I mean, you are guys going to
get in fights and arguments?
I mean...
-We haven't yet.
We said,
before the filming started,
"Who is going to be
the first one to flip a table?
That has not happened yet.
-Oh, you have to!
-The tables in our house
are heavy.
They're hard to flip.
-You got to be --
Go get, like, a really --
like, a plastic table
or something outside
and practice that.
You have to flip a table.
-Like, a very dramatic scene.
-Luckily, we have not had
any of those.
We don't --
-We don't really --
-We don't argue
that much anymore.
-Not with words.
With our eyes more.
-Yeah.
We're, like, literally like...